[موسيقى]
وانا وصغيره كتير كنت احب ارسم قصص لما
صرت جامعه صارت الناس تحب تاخد رسمات
وتبروزها وتحطها عندها بالبيت كنت احس
حالي زي اللي حابه اعيش كذا حياه بنفس
الوقت فاذا ما بقدر انا اعيشهم بقدر
اعيشهم خلال شغلي كان عندي خوف لانه انا
بالنسبه لالي كانوا هدول اشي كثير خصوصي
في مره اصحابي اخذوا اغراضي وحطوا لي
اياهم بمعرض وكانت اول مره شغلي بنعرض
لقدام الناس
طبيات شغلي بشكل عام بتقدر تندرج تحت
الاسلوب التعبيري بالرسم ناس ممكن اكون
قابلتهم اماكن ممكن اكون زرتها انطباعات
اخذتها عن اشياء معينه بتصير حوالي كل يوم
اكثر موضوع بستعمله هو المراه بتهمني
النظره اللي عم بحاول اعكسها بتكون تعكس
مثلا مزاج معين انا كنت احس فيه بهذاك
الوقت ملامح نفسها مثلا ان كان غضب ان كان
قهر ان كان سعاده ان كان حب ان كان حزن
كنت كتير استعمل الرصاص والفحم بعدين صرت
اكثر استعمل الالوان المائيه بحب الاشياء
اللي فيها فراغ انه اللوحه نفسها بتحكي
الحبر هو اكثر ماده انا بحب استعملها
لانها كتير انسيابيتها فيها حريه او علي
ارسم 24 ساعه باليوم ما بقصر وبحس ممكن
ترسم على اي شيء حواليك ما في اشي بقول لك
لا
اي حدا عنده رؤيه شخصيه او اشي بحب يعمله
ما يوقف لانه رح يسمع كتير اصوات حواليه
بتقول له مش وقته ما له داعي في كثير غيره
كان احسن وما زبطت معه ما توقفوا لانه
بالاخير ما بتعرف كيف الدنيا مرتبه امورها
لالك
واذا اشي حقيقي نابع منك من جوا الا ما له
مكان بهالدنيا
[موسيقى]